a lot of discussion recently about you
know what could be possible with
location-based services and often focus
immediately jumped to these days because
it's Mew Piqua tiss in GPS but the fact
it's interesting to understand the phone
kept little food companies have known
where you are for a long time and
perhaps where you just you know try to
understand exactly how how well they can
localize you based on the very
fundamentals of how the gsm network has
worked in the past in general in
computer networks we have to arrange
that when if we're using a shared medium
as we call it
so really aware of this one but
traditionally wired Ethernet before we
had switched Ethernet when I was just
sharing media similar have to make sure
that two people aren't talking at the
same time as garbage in the case of
Ethernet it was very simple in the olden
days when you just have a single wire
and people tapped into the wire you
listen to for a while and if you didn't
hear anyone using it you sent a packet
and you kept listening and if the packet
was transmitted and you didn't see any
corruption in the packet
you know it probably got there whereas
if someone else happened to listen at
the same time and start transmitting at
the same time you would get what was
called the collision boat both of you
would see both of your packets and I
would read his garbage off the line so
you'd know to back off and so he was
then back off randomly try again later
and was a whole protocol their media
access control it's called we do very
similar things in Wi-Fi people try to
transmit and in fact the Wi-Fi base
station will send a response saying I
got you or I didn't the reason that we
don't quite do the same thing as
Ethernet there is that you have what's
called the hidden station problem is so
remote my mobile device and your mobile
device may be able to see the base
station but we can't see each other so
we can't see that with the broadcast at
the same time
very quickly very quickly yeah in human
terms about how you ran away in the case
of the Ethernet it was you would try and
then if you didn't get through
microseconds later you would randomly
try again and then you know either polls
for randomly at a time or not and
whoever got in first would get in the
other one get in immediately afterwards
and you know all sorts of interesting
properties proved by it how that
stabilizes even at very high numbers for
users so Wi-Fi significant the mobile
phone network so well the first thing is
reasonably obvious the mobile phone
network needs to know that you're near a
base station so here's our base station
really anything radio waves
when we send our data which can be
either the voice communication or
whatever it doesn't matter it's the raw
channel radio channel that carries this
essentially as far as the base station
is concerned it chops up time into
little time windows it allocates one of
these time slots to a particular mobile
phone so here's mobile phone hey here's
mobile phone be and say gets this one be
gets this one in order for this to work
when a and B transmit they have to
arrange that when their packets arrive
at the base station that they arrive
this one in this time slot and this one
in this time slot and they could be
different distances away and so they
have to decide when to transmit so that
they arrive at the transmitter at the
right time and the further away you are
you have to in a sense advance your
communication in order that it lands at
the right time you don't wait until your
slot comes up and then try to transmit
it you have to transmit it in advance
and that means that you have to know the
distance between the mobile on the cell
tower and so the first thing is we can
say that if it's a cell tower here the
phone company knows you're somewhere
within a band or annulus around the cell
tower so they know you are three miles
from a cell phone it's actually the way
in which this protocol works is one of
the reasons gsm was specified to be able
to deal with a mobile moving at a
certain speed and that's to do with the
rate at which you can they do this
calculation about how far your way
if you move too quickly you will find
that your you're transmitting either too
late or too early depending whether
you're going away from the cell tower
coming to it so on a high-speed train
sometimes jsm didn't work and of course
over the years given the things are
moving faster you know we've just had to
make these protocols a bit smarter as
well there's one other thing that they
often do in very high density areas for
example in cities we an often build a
cell tower so looking down on a cell
tower which has multiple antennas I'm
sure people have seen these on buildings
and wondered what they were
it's called sector eyes done tennis or
what they do is they cover a sector and
so you can get much denser coverage for
a single Tower you can get a whole bunch
more sectors and each sector can support
a certain number of mobile phones so
instead of just supporting say a
thousand mobile phones within a ten-mile
radius you can get six sectors of thysen
phones each and very often in cities
you'll see these sector ice antennas on
top which of course no means given the
protocol and the sector ization you have
no isolated someone to be within this
zone they're not just three miles away
there are three miles away and they're
within this 60 degree radius at this
point if you were then to take this
information and say a map and you were
to Luke and say well what are the
feasible places this person could be and
given that we have some estimate of the
speed they're moving I mean this has
been the basis for example for
monitoring traffic on roads because if
you see a mobile phone moving at 70
miles an hour in between between the two
samples you're 70 miles an hour and the
two arcs of the sector cross a motorway
the chances are they were on the
motorway and so that's been used by a
number of companies to actually do
monitoring of the speeds on the roads
remotely from the data that's understood
by the phone network and you know if you
suddenly see all those phones the other
thing is of course they're all there's a
whole bunch of them going
how many phones are switched on and when
cars these days if you suddenly see them
all going at 50 miles an hour then you
might indicate that as congestion so
it's been used as a measure of
congestion the other thing I said maps
one thing is we can yes we can map this
onto roads and have a guess about things
and use it for insect traffic congestion
but other things are if if it's a
criminal who's being tracked then you
might be expecting that up to certain
nefarious things and if you just lay a
map down in this of a policeman like I
said I'm mapping this it looks a lot
they might go huh I think they're there
so for example if it wasn't he was
mostly barren wasteland or fields with
one vamos or something you've probably
identified where that person is now of
course
phone companies are very protective of
this information because you know if it
was if this was just to be publicly
available would be a disaster it being
the security and privacy disaster you
know given that everyone carries phones
I'm sure there are people who would love
to track politicians and carry a box of
eggs with them and see if they could
intercept them in various places so the
sensitivity around this has been
enormous but it is slightly frustrating
in that and all this time we never got
services that would actually tell us as
the user of the device where we were and
give us give us privacy preserving
services even if it's information that
there's that that many companies make
money out of the cell phone companies
will sell to a shopping center a
shopping mall in America they will sell
where the people during the shopping
mall have come from because they can
track them as they travel from their
home to to the shopping mall see that
there for a couple of hours so they can
actually tell you you know the people
who come in it's a sample of course it's
not it's not telling about everyone but
it's at least a sample of where people
come from so you might be able to tell
that this advertising campaign and this
time had a success because between this
weekend in the next weekend so those are
the sorts of data services that are that
are that don't share personal
information but do share statistical
information
from that's derived from your location
we map those then two books lake and
they will for our Gulliver's Travels of
all of these great classics of the old
field we should have read we all have
talked just and they lie somewhere on
our shelves and because we've got to
through the first two page and thought
this is hard work delete all your files
you run this algorithm to rewrite all
the file contents and arears them and
luayn hold all the contents are still
there